anthony fauci the man we were not
allowed to question
for two years the man who lied about
masks lied about social distancing lied
about what the nih was doing in wuhan
all of the stuff
well now he's kind of admitting that he
doesn't even know if lockdowns worked
i'm interested in your reluctance to use
the word lockdown do you think two years
on that they were worth it or were they
too severe
you know i don't think we're ever going
to be able to determine what the right
balance is i think the restrictions if
you want to use that word which i tend
to shy away from
lockdown this certainly prevented a lot
of infections prevented a lot of
hospitalizations
and prevented a lot of deaths there's no
doubt
about that
obviously when you do have that kind of
restriction on society
there are unintended
negative consequences particularly in
children who are not allowed to go to
school
in the psychological and mental health
aspects it has on children
in the economic stress that it puts on
society in general on individual
families
obviously those are negative
consequences that are unintended
or are they intended you freak so when
he talks about it prevented lockdowns in
f uh prevented infection hospitalization
hospitalization and death notice as
always he never gives you numbers how
many hospitalizations did it prevent
lockdowns locking people in their houses
it doesn't tell you that how much how
many people didn't die because of it
doesn't tell you that cause he doesn't
have data on that and when he talks
about the unintended consequences was it
not obvious from beat one if you locked
people down that alcoholism rates were
going to go up and drug use was going to
go up and depression and all sorts of
stuff that we have seen i mean crazy
rates of all of these things and i'd
love to see numbers on how many more
people are on prescription pills these
days as opposed to two years before
although i'm sure he would love that mr
science over there and what this all
proves is that desantis again i'm trying
to show you that there is a way to fight
back and it starts with the individual
because desantis is just one man
there is a way to fight back and what it
shows you is that when when all hell was
breaking loose some people didn't
completely lose their minds and in
florida they didn't completely lose
their mind so if any of it worked
if any of it worked the rates of covid
and death and hospitalizations and all
this stuff would have been completely
out of control here in florida and
completely under control in california
and you know what from all the studies
that i've seen and i welcome you to show
me counter studies it's been pretty much
comparable pretty much comparable on top
of the fact that florida has the second
oldest population in the united states
okay so they have lied about everything
and that's all they can do that's all
they can do and uh if you think dave
well no they don't lie about everything
they wouldn't just make up numbers and a
whole bunch more on that well first i've
got some info here on just generally
what has happened with covid this is
from the daily wire more than half of
americans 52 say they have contracted
the virus according to a new monmouth
university poll this appears to be the
first poll to show a majority of
americans saying they've been infected
at some point an august poll from the
pew research center showed that 30
percent had tested positive or were
pretty sure they'd contracted the virus
uh okay so that means a whole bunch of
people got it in states that did lock
down and didn't lock down and you know
what 99.9 whatever percent of people
survived and everyone should take
whatever precautions they think are
necessary but now back to the lying
because they do lie about everything
you're not going to admit this the cdc
yeah they bungled the numbers they're
they're admitting it now we've got more
from the daily wire here the center for
disease control updated its covid19
death statistics last week revealing
that the agency had included an
additional 72 000 deaths 72 000 deaths
that should not have been counted as
covid deaths the change impacted 26
states and all age groups the cdc
explained in a footnote that the
overcount stemmed from a coding logic
error yeah they forgot to carry the one
with a total of about 970 000 deaths
from covet 19 the extra death
the extra deaths compose about 7.5
percent of that number that ain't no
small number
416 extra pediatric covet 19 deaths also
represent a significant revision from
the initial data the question of how to
differentiate between how many deaths
were from coven 19 and how many deaths
were
deaths were with covid19 still remains
meaning that if you went to the hospital
and you had some other infection or
something else that was going to kill
you but you also had covet they would
just chalk it up to coven but okay so
there they lied all along about what
they were doing and whether it was
working or not they never really tell
you the numbers they fudge all the
statistics and now they're admitting oh
we had a coding error at the cdc you
know somebody is anyone going to be
fired is anyone going to be reprimanded
no no no because the machine is evil
people